[Music]  the springs preserve all decorated ready  for families to have a spooky good time  at the haunted harvest starting this  weekend  seven outdoor trick or treat stations  music something new this year also it's  called boo town  guests can walk down a historical street  of restored railroad cottages  and because they are limiting attendance  this year to allow for social distancing  tickets are selling out really fast in  fact the only tickets left are for  halloween night october 31st tickets can  only be purchased online in advance  they're nine bucks and discounted for  springs members we have a link at eight  news now dot com